have you heard the media fawn all over
Capitol Hill's latest immigration plan
well it's being billed as a bipartisan
approach which is a complete joke since
its sponsors are amnesty zealot John
McCain of Arizona and liberal Delaware
Senator Chris Coons if spill is
basically a rerun of the failed gang of
eight fiasco that flopped out back in
2013
remember that legislation was so
unpopular that even its original sponsor
Marco Rubio had to walk it back and now
he considers it a big mistake
so gang of 82.0 would grant legal status
in a path to citizenship to young
migrants who came here before 2014 and
that is a number that far exceeds the
1.8 million that President Trump was
willing to make citizens in his
compromised gesture and there would be
no border wall funding and it would keep
chain migration that entire scam would
keep going
so obviously this is a complete
non-starter for the White House meaning
McCain Coons was a stupid ploy not a
serious plan lawmakers who have been
shopping various amnesties for years
focus most of their empathy and concern
on illegal immigrants who fear
deportation not on Americans whose lives
have been devastated by illegal
immigrant crime
president Trump however hasn't forgotten
those people and today he focused on
closing immigration loopholes to keep
groups like ms-13 out of our country as
for the Democrats refusing to come to
the table
Trump's willing to play hardball if we
don't change the legislation if we don't
get rid of these loopholes where killers
are allowed to come into
country and continue to kill gang
members and we're just talking about
ms-13 there are many gang members that
we don't easily mentioned if we don't
change it let's have a shutdown will do
a shutdown and it's worth it for our
country I'd love to see a shutdown if we
don't get this stuff taken care of left
is going crazy because he said that but
that's how much he cares about the
country he cares about our safety the
rule of law the president knows that the
people are with him on this issue when
you look at the poll numbers
Americans want sensible immigration
reforms along with maybe curing the daca
problem okay here's a recent Harvard
Harris poll it found that 65% of voters
agree that any bill granting legal
status to dreamers should be accompanied
by funding for a wall an end chain
migration as well as an end to the visa
lottery system fifty-three percent
supported building a border wall
consisting of physical and electronic
barriers and a whopping 79 percent
wanted immigration to be based on merit
not on family connections or other
factors well I'm assuming neither
senator from Arizona bothered to
consider the new comprehensive study by
economist John Lott who will join us
later in the show professor lot
basically looked at all the illegals who
entered the Arizona state prison system
from the years 1985 through 2017 that's
33 years of data and what did he find
he says illegals were at least a hundred
and forty two percent more likely to be
convicted of a crime than other
Arizona's he found their sentences were
10.5 percent longer than US citizens due
to the severity of their crimes
he found that illegals were 163 percent
more likely to be convicted of first
degree murder than US citizens 168
percent more likely to be convicted of
second-degree murder
189 points 6 percent more likely to be
convicted of manslaughter illegals were
much more likely to commit sexual
offenses against minors sexual assault
DUI and armed robbery in 45.4% of
illegal immigrants or more likely than
other criminals to have been gang
members my goodness
here's a smattering of how just in the
past week illegals have added to the the
health and well-being of their
communities on Monday in Hartford
Connecticut where I come from onel
ironic Orazio a Mexican illegal pled
guilty to being part of a heroin ring
that extended to Alabama in Connecticut
Rhode Island Ohio and guess what he's a
boomerang visitor he was already
deported back in 2013 then there's this
charmer Salvador Gomez Lopez of
Montgomery County Maryland right nearby
Orem broadcasting from the Salvador an
illegal was urinating in public lovely
when a bystander tried to convince him
to pull up his pants and find a bathroom
instead Gomez pulled a box cutter out
and started slashing at the poor man's
throat there's a lot of gashes there now
last week three dreamers were arrested
in three different smuggling cases all
were daca recipients they were smuggling
human beings two were nabbed in
California and one in Arizona and this
is a heartbreaker five days ago in Rio
Vista Texas a young mother of two
Jennifer Smith on her way to pick up her
kids at school was killed in a horrific
car crash by illegal immigrant Candido
Martinez Ramirez 32 years old he was
drunk and this past Sunday many of you
have heard Indiana Colts linebacker
Edwin Jackson and his uber driver were
killed by an illegal intoxicated alien
37 year old Manuel array go Sal Bala the
DOJ announcing in just the last hour
that they will bring federal charges
against the Guatemalan proving once
again that Jeff Sessions is Attorney
General and as DOJ are moving quickly to
right the wrongs of the past when it
comes to a legal crime going unpunished
no more sessions is right this has to
look at these cases it's just a few just
the last week I could do a whole show on
this but you really start to think about
it it's total insanity we have enough
problems in our country with drugs the
opioid epidemic alcohol criminal
activity
we sure do not need anymore and yes of
course all illegal immigrants are not
criminals but frankly that's not the
point
because that's of little comfort to
Jenner Jennifer Smith sons or Edwin
Jackson's mother or the thousands of
Americans whose names you do not know
whose lives will never be the same again
because our government was unwilling or
unable to enforce our laws and that's
the angle